Your final project in this mini course
is to create a portfolio optimizer.
That might sound like a tough problem,
but you've already got
the tools to do it.
In this short lesson, we're going to
lay the groundwork to help you know
what portfolio optimization is and
how to build one.
First, what is portfolio optimization?
Given a set of assets and a time period,
find an allocation of funds to
assets that maximizes performance.
What is performance?
We could choose from a number of
metrics, including cumulative return,
volatility or risk, and risk adjusted
return, which is Sharpe ratio [LAUGH].
You can use any criteria you like,
but for this assignment,
we're going to focus on Sharpe ratio.
Now, let me show you how to use
a minimizer to optimize a portfolio.